I'm Chris Kyle I'm here at VidCon I'm
gonna add some people some hypothetical
questions they're gonna tell me where
they what it did I want to tell them
what I would've did this is what I
would've did you say I'm too old for
this
can I speak to your supervisor I guess
what we're going somewhere else
[Music]
your friend disappeared would you take
this house first
probably the dog lover oh you go get his
dog yeah because I lived with him so
it's like I raised it too so my friend
disappeared
first thing I'm giving the house and I'm
giving the computer and I'm deleting
that's my friend I know my friend India
what would you do if someone gets too
excited while you're telling them the
sex information like a little like you
could tell I will probably be mortified
so I wouldn't call attention to it
eyes up here what I would do I would
just start talking about worst-case
scenario penis you know you know what I
mean like wouldn't like if they have
something and like start describe it
like now with chlamydia what happens is
if you let it go on for 19 years
who would you do if you found a unicorn
pony how thick of the leg if I could
ride it but I would need to look at the
legs you get in there you if he lets you
just the leg I think you're milking a
unicorn I what do you think the milk
would be good it's like skittle no
skittles in know what would you do if
you spoke and auto-tune but rap and son
in a normal voice I would probably do a
lot of texting you know do you think
people would think you're in the matrix
well I'm trying to get the connection
from the voice to the main what would
you do if you start laughing too hard at
a joke toe by 9
you know that one dude on the side and
just keep laughing too hard like oh you
guys start roasting him yeah
what's you laughing yeah yeah you gotta
have this hand you want to use I gotta
fire down you do we always say gotta
head and then you come up I don't know
you but them sneaks though you establish
a territory got a chest out on okay yes
now you are compound roasted what would
you do is in your videos you couldn't
add a dramatic noise what do you do if
the government gave black people
reparations but it was literally three
acres of well I would you'll build a
house I would start my own compound and
I would start preparing for out of the
world because you know if they gave back
and reparations things things are
already done 30 we're already going
there the space for star laws yeah video
we're gonna find one Jim's they're all
edited hey they call me fix it impose
crisp
[Music]